vous êtes avertis vous avez vu le titre
vous pourrez pas pleurer après mon tort
c'est ainsi près de mon mollet
aujourd'hui on est sûr capture c'est un
jeune au scénario suit le même principe
que son se révèle un endroit qu'on ne
connaît pas cet accord c'est dégueulasse
il ya plusieurs pièces il faut à chaque
fois réussir une épreuve pour atteindre
la pièce d'après ses partisans- en
anglais mais des sous titres
s'afficheront pour que vous puissiez
comprendre vivront l'expérience ensemble
n'ayez pas peur je suis là ok
cinématiques
c'est le réveil je suppose
oui qu'ici au tour reste une porte
ok a lancé madame
l'essai
ok merci le monsieur diop alors c'est
très agréable de se réveiller dans ce
[ __ ] d'endroits dégueulasse pour qu'on
trouve un levier l'a dit ou une clé chez
pathé que c'était un piège
aucun peut prendre des choses est envoyé
au essayé par le biais dans cette
palette une boîte à capela uniquement
excellent abat un peu d'humour des
situations comme ça ce que j'amène ma
lin pas se mentir mais y'a quoi il ya
des tasses des bouteilles un bras de
levier apte et derrière ça oh [ __ ]
rien derrière ça rien non plus veillez à
la pomme s'est fermé la porte par
laquelle nous a amenés ici c'est très
bien ça là je vois rien ah je crois je
trouvais oui ok allez on prend des fois
son niveau
grosse soirée ici la veille apparemment
alors qu'est-ce qui est dans cette
nouvelle pièce
non ou pas je parle pour chasser en
sueur
mais je personnes spécialement bats les
couilles
georges la bad ragaz ces projets-là
copenhague agents de deux pompes à la
cherté de la vie au peut-être que les
bois bieber je n'ai pas les pierres à
louviers oui ça va faire quoi ça va me
libérer
il me suis pas assez bon ok donc un
levier qui va ouvrir la [ __ ] de porc
dans lequel le the butcher va l'appeler
va nous rejoindre au cameroun qu'on va
activer ce levier là une partie de ces
grella s'ouvrir pour qu'on puisse
accéder au deuxième levier sauf que la
porte qu'elle a va s'ouvrir aussi donc
le berkshire va venir s'occuper de nous
c'est parti
ciao
c'est ce qui fait son coup avec est
atteint la barrière d'accès pas
premièrement qu'à aller vite
les bacs
m
mais qu'en plus il a dit que c'était
chiant à faire tourner ses trucs de mer
et ce qui à votre avis à temps l'autre
se refaire au bruit le blâme c'est qu'on
va activer le levier pour pouvoir faire
ça lui va rentrer nous faudrait
peut-être l'attiré ailleurs grâce à ce
jeu c'est pas ça ça peut faire du bruit
sont en bas loin je suis tout
sympathique je me pisse dessus il ya au
revoir et si elle pas un truc fait masse
bourg ici des pots cassés un comme ça il
ira réparer les pots cassés
jeux de mots l'expression pour casser
compris de let's go n'a pas le choix ça
a marché mais que ça a marché
oh non ça n'est pas si j'ai fait faut
lancer des objets comme ça il va à omex
et je le plus angoissant du monde pour
qu'un dossier voilà j'ai réussi à
m'enfuir a ramené une deuxième bouteille
comme ça on aura deux trucs en faire du
bruit le problème c'est que tout à
l'heure il a été distrait pendant
suffisamment de temps pour gérer et pour
j'atteigne seulement la moitié du truc
mais qu'il faut six objets au total on a
deux cages entre deux bouteilles de peau
on peut s'en sortir la quatrième fois
oui ou tapis nous tue donc on a que
trois chances ça va être chaud est ok
il arrive quoi mais c'est faux rythme
mais un rêve je m'en bats les couilles
quelques chutes de neige pas à faire
chuter dans les geôles aux égoïsmes au
revoir à ça le rend fou non il va mourir
un mec je suis désolé mais je suis
désolé je pouvais pas j'ai pas ce que tu
fous tu essaie d'imiter son goût il s'en
sort super celle là
désolé désolé je suis désolé je suis
désolé je pouvais rien faire je suis
désolé je me casse j'essaie de la prise
ou comme une mère non mais il est trop
violent le boucher elle allait sortir la
douche que l'égoïsme dans les films
d'horreur comme sa soeur à chaque fois
ouais mais ça s'trouve j'aurai réussi
c'était un mensonge salut écrasé quand
même le crâne bon on arrive dans koala
dans une pièce sombre à est en tout cas
faire avec 7 prises en corse et sa
retraite culpabiliser de ouf ça se pose
alors 8 m'insulter ouais mais là c'est
oui tu suis aux commandes n'avait pas le
droit à un peu de compassion s'il vous
plaît soyez indulgents alors ça c'est
sous cage qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un
bouton moulin boutons noirs décor blanc
décor noir a + b noir blanc blanc noir
blanc noir noir blanc
mais du coup on a accès à sa [ __ ] mais
c'est horrible ce système là aller ou la
porte
mais mecs vous avez vu le taux qu'on a
mis en fait est là il nous restait mille
tours à faire quoi pourra brancher ne
serait-ce qu'une c'est impossible à
franchir qui semblent songeurs cleans
sur ce jeu et son foie et si c'est pas
le cas je m'abonne la chaîne suka russie
ne fait pas tous une vidéo sur ce jeu
demain non quand on est là pourquoi
pourquoi les ça bouge aidera ses
fantômes là dessous c'est quoi ce délire
à j'aime pas quand ça fait ça il ya un
mec là dessous à moi ça va clignoter il
y aura plus dray sera que des mecs boîte
en a 3 po ils sont pas là pour rien il
ya des fantômes il ya une cachette il ya
des mecs mort derrière encore et à une
flèche là qui va dans ce sens là il ya
trois boutons blancs commencer par celui
là d'après la flèche up celui-là ensuite
sa part et on arrive là bas donc là on a
combien 1-2 ce truc-là 3 4 5 1 à 5 avant
la limitation de la flèche qu'elle a
donc 5
ok ensuite y'a du la soif et jetés là ça
fait 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
je sais pas à peu près ensuite y'a les
corps plus tous ces trucs là pour ce
dernier bouton donc à cinq corps plus 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 objets y est on est
passés [ __ ] alors c'est ouvert le
fameux levier je veux juste plus jamais
au vert mais qu'elle rachète symplus
densifie
le maquis la tête sumatra c'est mon jeu
car je me calme car le calme kg battu
avec un poids car cette [ __ ] mais j'en
ai marche fort c'est beau mais le jeu
mon gars eh ben [ __ ] mais c'est pas
aimé la vidéo si ça vous a bien fait
peur bien c'est le même mécanisme qui a
fait le succès d'un coutelas seulement
c'est un mec qui peut te péter la gueule
et paul furent à tout prix mais ça m'est
vraiment dans l'ambiance et espèce de
voilà qui sort do pas rare qu'ils te
disent tu vas mourir
ouais je suis la vf du méchant dans soho
et puis tu as ces [ __ ] longs mois à
tourner et qui font un max de bruit
alors tu sais que l'hôtesse attiré par
le bruit donc ça te font encore plus mal
de la tournée mais tu as envie de sauver
le gars qui va se faire à lallaing bravo
vous venez de regarder une vidéo sur le
jeu le plus terrifiant qu'elles ont
déjoué les bains savoie gardien sortait
deux prochaines vidéos sur un jeu
beaucoup plus fun que tout le monde
savait ce que j'allais dire